[موسيقى]
إيران
نشطة للغاية في المنطقة مع
نشاطها السلبي سواء كانت
مستمرة في تزويد الحوثيين
بالأسلحة أو
تعريض الشحن في الخليج العربي للخطر
وهو ما
نعلم أن لدينا تقارير قادمة اليوم
قد تشير إلى نشاط إضافي
هناك  جزء من الدمار الذي
يحدث للاقتصاد اللبناني من خلال أه لأنك تعلم
المساعدة في الدخول في المأزق السياسي
الموجود في
جميع أنحاء المنطقة ، لا تزال إيران
تتشجع
[موسيقى]
لقد دعمناها عندما تم التوقيع عليها لأول مرة على
مضض لأننا اعتقدنا
أنها كانت أه  غير مكتمل
كوثيقة عدم انتشار ولكن أيضًا
لأنه سيؤدي إلى أي مبنى
في إيران
نسمع الآن من إدارة الكتاب المقدس
من الآخرين أنهم
ملتزمون بنهج أه أطول وأقوى
تجاه jcpoa لذا أه ما إذا كان
ذلك إعادة دخول إلى  gsp ثم إيجاد
طريق طويل جدًا وأقوى ،
فنحن مهتمون بسماع أنك تعرف
كيف سنحقق ما
هو  استراتيجية للوصول إلى هناك ندعمها بالتأكيد